you know when you and katie were working  out everybody made a very big deal about  the photo talk about that photo that  moment and that it was what it actually  was for you it goes back to your earlier  question like what did you give up being  jason taylor's like they exaggerate  everything i do i've known katie since i  was in high school we were on the usa  team together we spent five weeks  together last year from vegas to tokyo  we want to go metal like we have a  behind like that's my brother i'm not  too proud to say katie's one of the best  players ever so if like one of the best  players wants to work out with you and i  could learn some things for him like why  would i say no if you worry too much  about what other people think are going  to say you'll drive yourself crazy and  it's crazy that i can't work out with  somebody